Jackson look Home Troy Terry feeds F and a great
save on the stick by omark off seis made his way
down the tunnel but back now inaction and then
an effort-based attempt right here by Trevor zek
Troy Terry comes out of the pile with the puck and
a marvelous save byar zigris
fires away bakan off the end
boards banan distributes to goodess and it
goes in off a skate and Ryan stro will get
credit they win a puck battle they played a
low High game and then they get bodies to the
net stro with that one hand extended looks like
he may have got a piece of it the overhead will
show you what uh McTavish is doing looks like hit
the skate of hus Lindholm not sure if stro going
a piece right here or not does doesn't look like
it no I mean his reaction was if he scored it or
he got a piece of it but it certainly goes off
the Bruins defenseman and in behind Omar there
is a coach's challenge by Boston to determine
if there was go tender interference part of
puckering that was jiz Lane and bear a bear take
a look at MC davish I mean he certainly gets into
the crease on his own a little body contact with
lyol but now he needs to either get out of there
Carlson wins the draw lome Lofts the backand
off the Dasher and off a stashin jake de brus
gets thwarted by lome lome Jabs at the puck
comes free Matt grizzli De Brusque makoy has
open ice swings around the goal and fires
away Gibson that's save Charlie Coyle and
Adam Henri Cole wins the draw aoy marshan
maoy poock a slap pass to Charlie Coyle it's
[Applause] 1-1 replaces man re Dy wins the
draw and now the Bruins get into the motion
move the puck they good decisions with the
puck and ping KN with that fake one timer
I'm going to give him credit for the fake
onetime I don't think he miss byed but maybe
he did let's just say he didn't because it's a
perfect fake onetime slap pass Mar reach around
Patra protects the puck gets it back to
maoy grizzl finds the five [Applause]
hole but it's Matt ptra that makes this play
Jack he just hangs onto the puck it's man on
man right here and the minute he draws
a second player in this case Str it was
fou his guy stro comes over and now ptra
has two ducks on his backside he's able
to find the open man and that's makable
but the puck just penetrates through the
body and across the goal line 120 between
goals poock looking for a third and Gibson
makes the glove stop here's Leo Carlson MTO
good alert penalty killing by Patrick Brown
to M grizzli oh beater hit the post and
goodus gets it into the Boston zone zaka
poock out of play three and a
half minutes to go second period
brooms goal scores Charlie Coyle and Matt
grizzli and poock tries to join him and
does Saka in the mix it's
3-1 look at all this space here an opportunity
to carry the puck Carri to you get challenge
well Mago never gets challenge till he
gets to the offensive blue line and now
you're on attack you got Anaheim kind of
lost in coverage Deep In Their Own Zone
and poso is going to take full advantage
picks up speed through the neutral zone
he gets inside the dot he follows his
shot he gets helped by Zach on the net
[Applause]
Drive poock the long diagonal to marshan pot ra
plays it quickly geeky to Van re D
and Gibson does a 360 on his goal
line Coy strong on the stick Coyle
closes a shot with purpose and coil
feeds it right through the
creek Jake de Brusque blind
Holm Jake de bruss to
Frederick Saka oh Terry and carlsson scores
a lot of good opportunities in tight they
moved the puck quickly they created scoring
chances they had a couple of empty Nets that
they could have handled the puck themselves
and then finally Carlson zerus Lindholm off
Terry [Music] stro mof closes Terry score
Sam Carrick ties it with 15 seconds to
go this is the first time the Bruins
have given up more than two goals in a
game padra gets it to geeki Carlo it would have
counted Gibson makes the save just before the
siren Coy poock and makoy against
stro Pono and mikov and Anheim has
possession stro against makoy poock takes
the puck away and stro gets it back mikov
zis replaces stro Trevor Zess andar makes a
[Applause] game and the ducks have it back
Carlson McTavish wins [Applause] it the
Bruins were up two with two minutes to
go and Anaheim has a team Builder rallying
for three straight goals and winning it in